paradisi jawohl die reise hingehen zum
ersten fc union alte försterei eine
beziehung nämlich wirklich irgend hertha
fan aber sie haben die beziehung zum
ersten f10 ja klar ja schon immer gehabt
weil das war immer ein besonderer verein
und zwar sowohl zu ddr-zeiten als auch
heute zu ddr zeiten war das ein frecher
vereinsamen bfc dynamo war bei armee und
sicherheit und so weiter angesiedelt und
der erste senior überhaupt nicht horn
muss ich sie gebracht hat
ganz unten also fast nach jedem spiel
zumindest in alten försterei hatte ich
zwei neue mandanten in eine
untersuchungshaftanstalt rummels wo ich
mal da war immer remmidemmi da war immer
was los
und irgendwann die mir sympathisch
umfrage und ich muss mal sagen die heute
ihren fans sie haben das stadion
wirklich fast mitgebaut muss man sagen
ja und soweit sie können haben sie denn
auch aktien gekauft da geht es wenn ich
wirklich um wert sondern darum dem
ersten fc helfen sich auch aktien
schuljahren einer habe ich gekauft
jetzt mache ich wollte nie aktien kaufen
es ist ja es nach bin ich in meinem
leben gemacht werden weil die erfahrung
zu ziehen wenn sie die deutsche bank in
ihrem portfolio herr jan oder ist der fc
union wahrscheinlich relativ
unverdächtigen
dann weiß man ja das geld gibt man außen
sieht es nie wieder aber das stadion
entsteht eben dafür das ist auch okay
und sie fahren da jetzt zum
kindertheater sachen noch nervös vor
solchen wenig nervös also dem erstens
was er auf lampenfieber habe ich immer
wie es zb vor jeder talkshow ein
bisschen schlecht und dann wenn ich so
die ersten fünf minuten überstanden habe
dann ist gut und das zweite ist dass ich
zum beispiel ich habe
relativ regelmäßig eine matinee
veranstaltung im deutschen theater in
berlin habe ich immer ein gast da
bereite ich mich sehr gründlich darauf
vor
das gespräch dauert anderthalb bis zwei
stunden so etwas gibt es ja heute gar
nicht mehr im gespräch mit einer person
und ist es eigentlich immer ausverkauft
weil die leute sowas auch mal wieder
gerne erleben und aber sind sie da weiß
kostet mich viel zeit und wissen wir
warum ich das mache
weil wenn ich nur die drucksachen des
bundestages lesen dann kommt der tag an
dem ich glaube die schildern das leben
weil ich ja nichts anderes lesen und
dann sage ich immer kommt der noch
schlimmere dach das ist der in dem du
aussiehst für eine drucksache des
bundestages was ganz so ganz vergessen
wenn sie sich jetzt so die die
umfragewerte und so anschauen können so
da nicht manchmal verzweifeln sie sagt
in unserer gewinn besteht darin dass wir
innerhalb und außerhalb des bundestages
widersprüche artikulieren wo das keine
andere fraktion macht
ich sag mal nur ganz wenige themen
afghanistan krieg überhaupt
kampfeinsätze der bundeswehr sind immer
alle anderen fraktionen dafür wir
dagegen hartz4 die ganze prekäre
beschäftigung im kern unterstützen alle
anderen fraktionen wenig rente erst ab
67 und senken des rentenniveaus
unterstützen alle anderen fraktionen nur
wenig wissen ich will gar nicht dass sie
meine auffassung sind sie kennen ja
andere auffassung sein
ich sag nur der gewinn besteht darin
dass der widerspruch überhaupt
artikuliert würden gäbe es uns nicht
gäbe es im bundestag dazu gar kein
widerspruch wie man überhaupt die
gesellschaft verändert ich hab da auch
meine zeit gebraucht um das zu begreifen
jetzt bin ich gespannt das erste was sie
verändern müssen es dem zeitgeist und
das geht nur über verschiedene wege
dazu gehören bundestags reden dazu
gehören auftritte in medien
dazu gehört dass auch journalisten und
journalistinnen anfangen anders zu
denken
andere themen zu beschreiben und dann
entsteht ein druck auf die politik wird
sich der zeitgeist ändert und wenn
dieser druck auf die politik entsteht
dann ändert sich auch die meinung in
anderen partei und dann noch was anderes
umgesetzt selbst wenn ich sie wähle sie
sitzen ja da quasi irgendwie am
katzentisch
niemand möchte mit ihnen möchte mit in
der regierungsverantwortung übernehmen
das heißt ich würde sie wählen und sie
würden wieder nur eine opposition sein
und könnte man nur den zeitgeist ändern
aber könnte nie sagen so jetzt machen
wir ein gesetz reicht es dass man immer
nur so eine so eine mohrrübe davor sich
hängen hat und da immer hinterher geht
oder will man nicht ab und zu auch dann
wirklich mal sehen wo man sagt okay das
haben wir jetzt geschafft
in der politik ist es so als sie im
dezember neue hat sich anfängt
wie alt waren sie 89 habe ich gemacht
und hab für mathe klausur gelernt als
die mauer fiel
voten sie damals direkt an der mauer ich
bin ja von westberliner kommunisten
großgezogen worden und die wohnten immer
an der mauer waren weniger aber insofern
kenne ich das sehr gut und eltern waren
in der sed oder frage ich auch weil ich
hab jetzt bei meinen eltern so
beobachtet und habe nie verstanden warum
gehen die da so viel herzblut rein in
eine sache die sie jetzt seit 40 jahren
machen und eigentlich sind sie
wahrscheinlich der ich sag jetzt mal
platt der weltrevolution nicht
nähergekommen kein schritt das ist
natürlich nicht zu vergleichen
ihre eltern haben wahrscheinlich die
kraft geschöpft dass es ja großes als
vorsicht sozialismus lager gab wo sie
glaubten dass das letztlich 7 wird sich
durchsetzen wird
dass das ganze zum scheitern verurteilt
war aus verschiedenen gründen
kommt noch hinzu sehen sie mal wie ich
nur im dezember 1989 angefangen habe und
wo wir heute stehen
wenn wir bei der letzten wahl in den
alten und sieben der stück bekommen
haben 1990 am wir dort 0 3 prozent
bekommen
es ist doch voll krass aber so gesagt
ist doch was die wahl bringen zum
ausdruck wie die stimmung in der
bevölkerung ist und je mehr stimmen wir
haben desto mehr reagieren die anderen
parteien
wenn wir verlieren dann sagen die sich
na ja gut das problem hat sich erledigt
mit den linken wenn wir gewinnen dann
sagt sich sowohl die union als auch die
spd als auch die grünen wir müssen in
bestimmten punkten nachgeben um die
wähler wieder für uns zu gewinnen und
die wählerin das so verändert man eine
gesellschaft das funktioniert nicht so
die in dem sinne dass mein antrag stellt
wird dem stattgegeben sie haben ja schon
drei ihrer sieben leben bestimmt
abgelegt oder ich rede doch jetzt nicht
über meinen ende hören sie mal ein
bisschen unhöflich in der tat aber sie
haben ja sagt wenn ich minister werde
werde ich postminister da sagen die
leute mal es gibt doch gar kein
postminister mehr da sei eben passieren
so ein bisschen banken
um die linke der nach die sierra oder
einmal wissen sie man muss immer in die
nächste generation übergeben und jeder
der glaubt er sei unersetzlich wird sich
was wir hier alles schon hingestellt
haben
wahnsinn wahnsinn den eingang
diese witzige uhr da oft rot und gelb
sieht doch mal was aus diesen gab es
drei spiele
der fc bayern zum ersten highlight das
ist wirklich ein highlight und dann kam
hertha ja das gilt vielmehr auch ein
bisschen was dafür bezahlt aber sind
wirklich ziemlich preiswert dann weil es
zu vergleichen und das finde ich wieder
das hat schon ganz klein
solidaritätsgedanken na da muss man
relativ kräftig drauf drücken und dann
lässt dieses taxi wieder frei einen
schönen tag noch
tschüss ihre tasche nicht machbar
dann machen sie es gut